during covet what state do you think
handle covered the best
well we say handle Cove at the bit yeah
which one which one's policies when you
say handle code with them yes you had
first of all you gotta break that thing
you had you had testing you had your
vaccine then you had your mask being at
your businesses I think different states
did things well
the greatest problem was that they were
left to their own devices because of
gross ignorance coming out of the White
House be specific with the states which
one first I'm unpacking it first of all
I'm all first of all when you had states
that were forced to compete for
equipment and man that was just stupid
again you had failure of leadership
so when I look at I look at the various
States when I look at what California
did something's good
when I look at what excuse me
I said I'm walking through it okay
some of the lockdowns they had weren't
good when I look at some of the Mask
mandates that took place uh in places
like Georgia were good when I look at
some of the places in Florida good when
I look at some of the policies that took
place in New York state were good
because it was based upon nursing homes
it's based upon hospitals it that was
such a again the the problem that we had
Statewide was that you had such gross
neglect federally that it was disjointed
all around the country when you had
Maryland like flying private planes and
trying to find equipment and doing stuff
along those lines and they were able to
get some of that sort of stuff so you
had so you had Republican Governors
Democratic governors in different states
who were doing things well
wait wait wait wait wait I I interrupted
you hoping you would say it you said
what California did good with the
lockdown you said Georgia masked you
didn't say anything about New York what
they did right and what Florida did no
no what I said what I said I said you
didn't say what Florida I did I said
right I actually did and also I said in
New York in terms of what they were
doing with their nursing homes hospitals
how about Florida Florida Florida same
thing some of the mass mandates and also
and again also when it came to testing
what the problems that we saw again was
that this thing was so fast moving and
again no real Federal leadership so
these states were left to like fend for
themselves and I think one of the
greatest one of the greatest you know
most shameful thing is when the United
States they were overpaying for goods
and services when it should have been
run through the federal government and
actually streamlined States should not
have been competing against one another
in fighting for equipment when Maryland
Republican Governor Hogan was doing in
Maryland trying to compete against
democratic governor in Virginia
competing against a Democratic governor
in New York competing against a
republican governor in Florida that was
absolutely crazy yeah but again there
were some very good things thank God we
had folks who ramped up testing
facilities who ramped up who were using
stadiums and things along those lines
and so those things were good but there
were a lot of things that were bad let
me so let me ask you again it was some
good a lot of bad Roland how do you
judge a data specific to data how do you
judge
the best country to live in with the
best opportunities well here's the deal
when you when like we when you say that
yeah they have numerous factors there so
you go economic you go Health you go
education you go to quality of living
you go environment you go all of that
yeah and so there's there are reports
that or studies done that America not at
the top
there are other countries now here's the
deal we go oh my God that's not us are
there other countries better
educationally than the United States
yes
when it comes to our health care System
some parts of our system great I'm from
Houston
Texas Medical Center
uh uh MD Anderson Cancer Institute tops
in the country
the other aspect awful
what I recognize is that we ain't
perfect
we're good we're great areas but we are
great in other areas When We complain
about human rights abuses in China we
act like police violence don't happen
here the fact of the matter is there's a
big difference
okay tell it to the person who got beat
yeah it's a big deal yeah tell us a
person who got to be tell it to the
person tell the person who had the very
family member do the police violence but
go ahead that's don't don't pin the
position as a person not being
sympathetic to the law this ain't not
being sympathetic yeah I'm saying if so
there's I'm saying when you're when your
child or your son your dog's been beaten
and killed I lived in guess what I lived
in a country called Iran at a time where
you couldn't tell people you were
Christian and trust me it's not a place
to be well it's a very big difference in
China and U.S what what trust me but
trust me I've interviewed enough mothers
and fathers who've had children who've
been the victims of police violence who
will say guess what they didn't live in
Iran but their child is still dead right
I agree that's a catastrophic on what
happened I saw the video on Ty on Tyree
Nichols what happened uh I had a hard
time watching you know what I haven't
heard and he has my mom Republican
friends this year the the billions that
we spend every year on police
settlements do you know who I rarely
hear saying anything fiscal
conservatives let me come back I wonder
why let's we'll finish how about we
finish it off with that that's fine
let's stay on this topic here you said
judging a great country right right and
you said all those different things okay
great how do you judge a great
restaurant
well
customer service okay
cleanliness yeah
quality of food yeah Ambiance some
places it's the music yeah all depends
on what you all depends on what you like
what's your favorite food what do you
like oh first of all my grandpa's from
Louisiana it's gumbo okay all right
local I'm good with that uh okay so when
you see what is the most packed
restaurant where you're at right now
packed restaurant like Friday night is
jam-packed and I
it could be the hole in the wall
with great food it could be STK it can
be prime 112. there you go hail I'm from
Texas and it's two o'clock in the
morning damn it is Whataburger there you
go okay
you don't eat man with you so it ain't
it ain't no Michelin yeah it's just time
and place
who the hell I'm with you so so but a
part of it comes down and not in and out
Whataburger so well listen this is team
in and out here just want to let you
know we're willing
have you tried Five Guys or not first
dude I try Five Guys but it ain't
Whataburger I don't want salad dressing
on my burger
it's ketchup I lived in Texas five years
I can't do it see that's wrong but
here's a part I'm glad you left but team
Whataburger you left as well no I didn't
where are you living I'm a registered
voter in Texas but where are you living
on my house what are you in both places
nah come on now now you I ask you I'm
trying to tell you stop it I'm trying to
tell you so let me go back to this the
way to just pay them down property taxes
the way to judge you're also paying
state taxes in Texas which I'm sure you
appreciate but you're not you don't pay
state taxes in Texas that's the point so
you like the state taxes
of course I know I get that and that's
it I would much got to pay Texas a state
income taxes in Virginia yeah but you
still have a lot of property taxes so so
nowhere Hospital District taxes and
school taxes would you flip it would you
rather play would you rather pay the
property or the state taxes are based
actually
I looked at both and it's really based
upon no I'm trying to tell you it's
based upon where you actually live I'm
trying to tell you state so you would
take 13 state taxes of California I just
pay lower real estate nice trick trying
to go to California you mentioned
Virginia in Texas what I'm saying is
when I look at both of them I'm looking
at priorities in those places and what
you're actually paying let's stay on
this year okay so you just go there the
the way to judge a great country to me
one of the best factors is immigration
okay America leads it with 41 million
okay China's losing their net people are
leaving Russia is losing actually first
of all China's first of all they're not
leaving China's one child policy 30
years ago screwed them nobody but
there's both but it's their birth you're
right but they're also leaving yeah but
the dealers if you were still having
kids you're not worried about who's
leaving but people are leaving they had
kids you're right but people who the
hell thought that was a good idea but
and guess what the fact that they can
stop you can't catch up yeah so here's
the other part so the other part is when
you look at uh policies during covet who
did it best what's the best way to gauge
it you said those things those items
right again
there's no best way to gauge it because
that is going to be subjective it's what
do you think was most important do you
think vaccines do you think keeping
businesses open do you think testing
what was most important do you think uh
Mass updates is one reason with you
there's no no reason I just don't I'm
just simply not agreeing with you there
are different ways to assess what you
think so it's best so based upon
priority so let me ask you so you watch
sports yes what do you like
what do you mean Wildlife are you going
Eagles or chiefs I don't give a damn
about either one of them Easton so
you're Houston see I'm born and raised
in Houston I don't care who wins Astros
these are astross Houston okay what does
Houston mean so I got you anybody in
Houston right so so I don't give a damn
who wins so does the score at the end is
it subjective no there's a score there's
a score okay so is there a way to have a
score on what state handled no it's not
really because no no no there is but it
is still subjective because that will be
weighing whatever however you want to
apportion and football is simple
six points for a touchdown one point for
p-a-t three points for field goal two
for safety okay that's the deal over
here it's subjective it's whoever she's
decided I am just curious what the rate
she's gonna say with this so the fact
that California had its first net loss
to population since 1851 and that New
York lost 330. is there any of that
that's subjective to you
why people leave people leave for
various reasons first time since 1851
California had a net loss okay and right
now we have here's the whole deal I look
at what happens so for instance when we
were taught we were talking about with
the basis of my book wide fear we talk
about Nation becoming majority minority
by 2043 why is that white folks stop
having kids
okay why is that why is the average
death rate among white Americans hiring
in 12 States the average birth rate I
when when something happens I'm going
back to you and your housing appraisal I
didn't see the data
you have to ask the damn question why
why is this happening why is the Rust
Belt losing population one of the
reasons the Rust Belt is losing
population because when you get the
great migration of African-American from
the south to the north where were they
going Chicago they were going to Gary
Indiana they were going to Detroit they
were going to St Louis in those places
what has been happening there have been
people who are like you know what we can
move back home land issues and so if
somebody if I'm looking at something I'm
then go okay why are they leaving not
just oh they're leaving I can't assign
it to covet I can't assign it to just
this I need to know why people are
leaving have they been surveyed
can you pull up power versus Force just
pull up power versus Force I just want
to show something to you this book
changed my life I I would recommend go
to images go to images if you can I just
want to that this this book is a
life-changing book Oprah Winfrey uh
talked about this a long time ago go to
the one that says the color the color
the color uh bottom left yeah that one
right there
so it explains different levels that we
go through shame at the bottom which is
the lowest level of consciousness
then it's guilt apathy grief fear desire
anger Pride courage
neutrality willingness acceptance reason
then you gotta love joy peace
Enlightenment okay I feel like you can't
be wrong at all okay and I it's it's
mathematically impossible to have a
conversation to say I think this is
where we got it wrong here's what we
could do this I don't see a I don't know
if there's an ability to say I can see
how we can improve in this area I can
see how we can improve in that area
based on the conversation I'm having
with you but you run a company we do the
exact same thing in companies the
realities is here when I'm looking at a
show yeah folks go like was that a great
show
oh I think they'll they'll say this is a
great show no no no no no no no no no
violent no when I'm what I'm saying
right because I own a company right it
was it's my goals row that was a great
show
to them that was a great show
to me I'm looking to show a different
way right I'm looking at Graphics speed
of playing Clips I'm looking at that so
I may not say it's a great show that's
what I'm saying it is subjective based
upon who is answering that particular
question and so you may have numerous
studies or surveys just like like I love
these surveys when they say uh the
greatest the the cities with the best
food
you go
huh how the hell is that City number
three
I've been there again it's subjective
and so that's all I'm saying when I'm
looking at something like your question
about covet it varies depending upon
what you think was the most important
thing that's all I'm saying so I'm not
saying that city was awful first time
California has lost its population since
1851 you said because whites are not
having babies no no no no that's not
what I said no that's not what I said
say again though what did you say no
what did you say are you actually
actively listening I am 100 this is what
I'm saying what I'm saying is when
something happens yeah like losing this
eczema people sense this my first thing
is hmm
why
you haven't said that you haven't said
it
why it's the second question we you got
to be deeper than muscles on a hot dog
okay yeah when that again for me when I
see something I go why when I saw when I
remember watching 60 Minutes in China's
one child uh deal I was kind of like and
I look good right now but trust me it's
gonna catch up so a couple months ago
when I saw they were complaining about
the lack of folks working in
manufacturing facilities and I was like
you can you can trace what's happening
with China's population right now
to that one child policy because that's
30 years of kids and never being born so
what I'm saying is we got to be deeper
than just throw it out there we try to
we got to ask the question why possible
I've been asking you it's not true why
questions when you threw out crime well
I walked through when you what is hold
on
I specifically say it I asked here are
the reasons why why it's Austin's fault
it's Republicans it's not State's fault
it's this there was no answer so okay so
if you enjoyed this clip you want to see
another one click here to watch another
clip and if you want to take advantage
the latest gold signature serious
products that just came out we have a
bunch of new merch that's out this is a
color changing mug when you drink coffee
that lion turns into a real lion and
then we have hoodies what about you Tim
and gold on it the gold Signature Series
hat shirts I'm an entrepreneur anyways
we have a lot of items they're selling
out if you want to take advantage the
gold signature series click here place
your order Sports your right taming gear
and tag us with the hashtag
valuetainment
[Music]